so this meme of the week from the
discord server comes from JM 93 and it's
a meme about Batman realizing that
Superman is Clark Kent
essentially what Superman writes an
article Batman makes fun of them and
then basically draws like glasses on his
face old I realized that Superman is
Clark Kent he's like did he really write
an article about himself I thought I was
pretty hilarious so if you guys want to
be featured in our meme of the week make
sure you guys go check out the discord
server down in the description hang out
in the meme section post up your best
memes and maybe you will get a shout out
on the channel
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today on our beyond Omega level video
we're going to focus on a character
that's relatively new to Marvel Comics
but in the short amount of time since
his debut has become an extremely
popular character the cosmic Ghost Rider
a cosmic Ghost Rider was created by
Donnie Cates and Jeff Shaw and was first
seen in Thanos number 13 in January of
2018 now I have a full video on the
origin of cosmic Ghost Rider that you
could check out but we'll go over it
here somewhat briefly but to explain the
origin of cosmic Ghost Rider we have to
really look at a few different
components that make up his character
because he's somewhat of a composite of
existing Marvel characters and concepts
so first the cosmic Ghost Rider was
originally the Frank Castle of his
universe Frank Castle in the main Marvel
Universe is the Punisher who became a
vigilante after his wife and son were
murdered dedicating his life to ridding
the world of violent criminals now in
the cosmic Ghost Rider's universe which
is yet to receive an official numerical
designation from Marvel
Frank does become the Punisher but once
they most destroyed his entire plan to
appease mistress death Castle demands
vengeance against him and that's where
our next concept the spirit of vengeance
comes into play
now when castle cries out for justice
he's approached by the demon Mephisto
who makes Castle into the next Ghost
Rider after striking a bargain with him
now we aren't told the specifics of the
bargain that castle makes with Mephisto
but what we do know is that after
becoming the Ghost Rider Frank Castle
basically goes crazy as he wanders the
earth with essentially no one to
interact with because Thanos had killed
everybody now eventually Frank
encounters Galactus who himself is
fleeing Thanos his killing spree across
the universe and ultimately Frank Castle
convinces the devourer to make him his
Herald so the two of them can destroy
Thanos now eventually Galactus agrees
imbues Frank with the power cosmic which
is a source of limitless energy that
enables his reelers to do a variety of
things like teleportation forcefield
creation and energy blast as well as
mataman emulation and a range of other
abilities but once Frank receives the
power cosmic his transformation into the
cosmic Ghost Rider is complete but his
story does not end there as after Thanos
kills Galactus he can scripts castle to
be his right hand as he rules over the
universe now as far as his powers go the
cosmic Ghost Rider derives his abilities
from both the spirit of vengeance and
the power cosmic now like the rest of
the ghost riders
Frank Castle does possess the penance
stare which forces victims to feel pain
equal to the amount of pain they've
inflicted on others throughout the
entirety of their lives he's also able
to create and control Hellfire
which is able to enter the souls of
those exposed to it and the cosmic ghost
rider was able to produce enough
Hellfire to wipe out the entire horde of
Annihilus with little difficulty as well
as melt Thanos has faced off with his
fire now the power cosmic also grants
cosmic Ghost Rider an incredible amount
of power he's produced energy blasts
strong enough to knock the nose off a
cliff and incapacitate him the power
cosmic also greatly enhances Frank's
physical attributes such as a strength
speed and agility he's been able to move
too fast for the Chitauri tracking
computers to detect his movements and
can move across the galaxy in the blink
of an eye when the power cosmic and the
spirit of vengence work in tandem the
cosmic Ghost Rider is even more
formidable having battled and killed a
large group of superheroes including
cable Iron Man Wolverine Hulk spider-man
beta ray bill Cyclops storm vision and
others which the totality of those
heroes have been enough to take down
some of the strongest villains in the
Marvel Universe when working together so
the fact that cosmic Ghost Rider can
wipe all of them out single-handedly is
quite impressive in and of itself
now both the power cosmic and the spirit
of vengeance work to make Ghost Rider
effectively immortal and virtually
impervious to harm he has survived
repeated punches and I blast from Thanos
of lashing Galactus meaning that even
the power cosmic itself cannot hurt him
even Thanos himself right after he kills
Galactus and just before recruiting
friend to his right hand remarked that
he would be unable to kill the cosmic
Ghost Rider
finally the cosmic Ghost Rider has some
unique equipment to bolster his powers
including twin pistols that shoot
hellfire his motorcycle that's powered
by Hellfire and the power cosmic as well
as teams that are made from the bones of
cyttorak the entity that gives
juggernaut his power as well as a piece
of the time stone now given the number
of appearances that he's made since he's
such a recent creation we don't really
have a whole lot of feats that
demonstrate just how powerful cosmic
Ghost Rider really is however he does
describe the centuries that he ain't
Galactus spent tracking down Thanos and
remarks of the feats of a had achieved
had become legendary but once again we
don't really know what they are things
are also somewhat complicated by the
inconsistency that's shown and how
powerful he's portrayed to be before
example although he can travel through
the universe a presumably faster than
light speed he was shown to be outpaced
by Nova and despite standing up to
Thanos and Galactus without suffering
much injury
he's been damaged by much lower tier
characters like Kamala Khan and Iron
Fist but despite these inconsistencies
given that he's a wielder of the power
cosmic we know that he's capable of
destroying
and he said as much stating that he has
to hold back to keep from destroying the
world as he walked now if we take this
statement at face value which I think we
can do to the fact that we've seen other
heralds of Galactus that can do some
pretty powerful things
we're pretty much safe in placing cosmic
Ghost Rider and Beyond omega-level but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end let me know
what you guys think let me know who you
think we should cover for our next
character on the Omega Beyond Omega
level series with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments explain
and make sure you guys at the sub button
to become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
please we've got some new patrons in our
top tiers over on patreon.com slash
comments explained I want to give a
shout out to Jason see Austin s Jason s
Austin H Phillip and Austin B as well as
Steven Z Eagle F Joey M and Jeff are as
well as Genesis 916 as always we just
usually keep the last name - an initial
it helps you guys to maintain your
anonymity some of you guys are expressed
concerned about having like your first
and last name thrown out there for the
world to see I do not blame you for you
guys who have joined up as part of our
patreon tiers that are eligible for Rob
core honor guard rings those whose rings
have been sent out you should already
have them if you're a new person who
just joined up and you've been part of
this here for a month your ring will be
mailed out to you so I want to say thank
you guys for being patrons
[Music]